conservative investigative group project
Veritas has posted a new probe into
Google and the way the search engine
alters its algorithms the video includes
an interview with a whistleblower and a
secretly filmed conversation with a
company executive there are highly
biased political machine that is bent on
never letting somebody like Dobbs
Holcomb the power
[Music]
YouTube's a subsidiary of google has
banned the video from the platform the
link now shows a blank screen with a
message stating the video had broken
privacy rules but our teachers Donna has
seen the film in full it's a household
name for everything searched online it
hosts those stupid videos you watch when
the boss is not looking and there's a
new service coming in 2020 electing the
US president at least according to
activists from Project Veritas who say
they interviewed an insider from Google
right after Donald Trump won the
election in 2016 the company did a
complete 180 and what they thought was
important before they about
self-expression
it could have everyone the voice was
important but now they're like hey
there's a lot of hate and because of
there's a lot of hate and misogyny and
racism that's your reason why I don't
Phunk got elected and so we need to fix
that I need to start policing our users
because we don't like to have an outcome
like that we don't want to have and I'll
collect that to happen again
you sure can search on Google but who
said anything about finding according to
the documents which are alleged to have
come from the same anonymous insider the
algorithms will move down those results
they deemed quote unfair and trust me
Google's algorithms aren't voting for
Trump this document is about algorithmic
unfairness it reads quote for example
imagine that a Google image query for
CEOs shows predominantly men
even if it were a factually accurate
representation of the world it would be
algorithmic unfairness Gogol secretly
adding filters for its search is like a
loan shark
adding interest points in the finest of
prints at the bottom of a hundred page
document except Google does that in
invisible ink but search is by far not
the only tool in Google's arsenal a web
browser smartphones tablets laptops PCs
an operating system for phones tablets
and smart TVs the world's best seller
that has over two-and-a-half billion
active users monthly Google can tinker
with any of those anytime at its whim
and apparently it plans to do so
according to the head of responsible
innovation
[Music]
now how's that for innovation or how's
that for don't be evil
how's that for do the right thing actual
slogans Google promises to a bite to
proudly but why not play God when it's
totally the right thing it's pretty
scary that there are also my first
results to match their definition of
fairness because it just in a matter of
a few people's hands what they deem is
fair and what they deem is unfair really
their fairness term is kind of a
smokescreen like the person was saying
in the video that like the insider was
saying it's more about their particular
political viewpoints at Google they are
published inserts and stories they're
curating news specifically for the
actual goal of not having a particular
person in the White House that is clear
election interference what Google is
doing is way way way more damaging and
actually legitimate compared to the
Russia conspiracy theories that have
been floating around
you